[Music]
from a slithery snakes Joe always to
whiskey on the rock to super young Joe
always to happy we simply can't get out
of our heads right now god he's not even
your youngest boyfriend
welcome to et's new jams with Alex and
Dez I'm Desiree Murphy and I'm Alex
underman and we are writers for easy
online and this is et's deep dive into
the latest and greatest in the world of
music
get out your pumpkin spice lattes
because we are kicking off our first
ever show by talking about an artist
that simply can't help ourselves from
making headlines lately the new edgy
Taylor Swift so her latest album
reputation is scheduled to be released
on November 10th but we've already been
gifted with three songs of it which
we're gonna break down one by one and
after that we'll give you predictions
for the album feast on the first three
songs that we've heard so far but first
up we got to discuss the debut track
look what you made me do the old Taylor
is dead meat new Taylor Swift she's back
with her first album since 1989 but this
time she's not rocking the sparkles
she's gone full-on edgy but to be honest
we've kind of seen this look coming from
her yeah yes at the Met in 2016 she
rocked this Louie Vuitton Python outfit
right and then here at the BMI pop
Awards another sultry snake like a look
and then here on the cover of Vogue guys
she's been giving us clues I am digging
the new aesthetic except the album is
bad I would agree with that I didn't
love that but but that's okay
like it's look like bad album art can
lead to great outlets all the time it's
very true but anyways let's break down
first off we want to talk about is the
new Taylor dead we'll get into that
later but we got to break down
everything of how she took us by
surprise I don't like you so basically
she did everything unexpectedly wiped
away all of her social media and then
she gives us the information about a new
album that's coming and then she gives
us a song and then a music video so in
the music video basically she is kind of
poking digs at herself but also Kim and
Kanye and Katy Perry which of course she
has all of her infamous useless I just
realized it's like The Dark Knight like
she like went away cuz this town didn't
need a Taylor oh and then she came back
evil yeah so it's like if the Dark
Knight was about Harvey Dent was that a
good theory I haven't heard this theory
so I'm writing it not a good theory I
would say like a 5 out of 10 500 there's
been a ton of fan theories out there and
one of them if you look at the very end
of the music video there are 15 Taylor's
and there's also 15 tracks on the album
which is interesting a lot of people are
wondering if those 15 Taylor's match up
to the each of the songs but I actually
I'm skeptical of this now because like
what Taylor is gorgeous you know I've
been thinking it might be the biker
Taylor because she's coming back badass
she's drinking now Oh biker Taylor would
drink alright anyway that brings us to
one that seems to have gotten lost in
the shuffle
maybe yes it's my personal favorite but
I might be the only one on earth who
thinks I don't know Michel likes it
Michel likes it that's true it's been
going on recent very recent family it's
a grower
yeah some people just weren't ready for
it are you ready for me I wasn't ready
for it and this is very silly and this
is me poking fun at myself just like
Taylor would but I am a huge college
football fan go South Carolina and it
really bothered me that she debuted it
during a football game
so Taylor whatever she drops the song
there's so much to it there's so many
clues I just want to sit down I want to
listen to it I want to tweet to everyone
and talk about it yeah but if I'm
watching a football game that's not what
I'm gonna do is just gonna completely
let go or my head I I think you're a
brilliant person and I think that's an
insane opinion and here's why because
like look at the lyrics for the song yes
it's hey hey let the games begin
right yeah but I don't I don't want it
for my college football games you know
one of her cards you don't want the game
to begin
[Music]
know how South Carolina doing by the
light they're doing good it's not even
just that it's the fact that she's kind
of talk wrapping in this and I feel like
if you're going to do that you have to
make it memorable and for me it just
didn't do that
[Music]
do you think it's talked rapping we've
debated this we have debated I don't
think it is cuz like is twenty one
pilots rapping I wish I found some
better sounds no one's ever heard that's
questionable like is Ed Sheeran rapping
club is the best place to find an
opposite above it where I go I think
like we're judging her so much for like
percussive singing and we should just
let her do her thing I think it's good I
think it's really awesome and then the
course is dope I do like the chorus I
will say and then let's move on now to
gorgeous which is my personal favorite
out of the three I will admit though
that when I first heard this I wasn't so
sure it's kind of listening to it like
okay I feeling this maybe maybe do I
like it do I not yeah
but then after listening to it more and
more and more I'm like this song is so
freakin catchy and ever since she
dropped it now it hasn't been on to my
head I'm like trying to go to sleep in
the end
[Music]
don't get out she started it with the
teaser mm-hmm which we don't like
teasers yeah we don't like users um no
one agrees and beyond this but I get
like an LCD soundsystem you said that
yeah am I crazy
yeah look weird this is a it's a good
song and um what everyone wants to talk
about with gorgeous so it's the first
reference I think ever of Taylor
drinking like she's never mentioned
consuming alcohol in a song and calling
it by name like she's actually saying
whiskey
[Music]
and spells it without the e-class
which i think is allowed yeah I looked
that up on the internet and the internet
says it's allowed yes like that's a
that's good that's an alternate spelling
everyone wants to talk about like the
debate about like who the song is about
mhm I think it's pretty obvious that
it's about Chihuahuan yeah there were
some questions about whether it was
Calvin Harris or Tom Hiddleston or her
current boyfriend which is Joe but she's
been having these fans only listening
parties and she actually reportedly
confirmed at one of these that it is in
fact about Joe and she confirmed in the
lyrics yeah I give you a listen it's
obviously about Joe Alwyn in the lyrics
cuz she goes and I got a boyfriend he's
gonna older than a saint like he's in
the club duel and I don't know what boom
Calvin Harris yeah Calvin Harris is a
deejay
this is the music show we know a lot
about Calvin Harris is a DJ is obviously
about Joe Alwyn because the only other
dude she dated or allegedly dated was
Tom Hiddleston yes are you weirded out
by like how obsessed she is with the
fact that Joe Arwen is younger yeah yes
because he's not how much younger he's
only about a year younger than her
you're younger than her and he's not her
youngest boyfriend that's true she
didn't Harry Styles Harry Styles Connor
Kennedy like she needed the littlest
Kennedy she needed the youngest Kennedy
you could possibly date because she's
dead we asked in the beginning is the
old Taylor really dead and this song
makes me say no because here she is
doing what we've always seen her do
basically dedicating a whole song to a
new boyfriend or a love interest I will
say though that these lyrics are fun I
like the fact that she's straight up
being like I'm a cat lady this is cool
this is who I am but that's totally
owning it I think the old Taylor is dead
or like this album it's kind of I think
it's like from the other side so this
this to me is about like you you are
seeing her like dating someone but then
they brings in the drinking mhm and she
kind of makes herself the villain of the
story
yeah which she doesn't really do
previously I think it's just about like
allegedly like living without this like
persona for the public there's nothing
just stumble on home to my cats yeah and
I want to go back to ready for it really
quickly because there's a line in here
that kind of goes along with gorgeous
says he can be my jailer but into this
tailor every love I've known in
comparison is a failure
and obviously she is referencing Richard
Burton and Elizabeth Taylor yeah and
back in the 60s when they were working
on Cleopatra they were both married at
the time and they kind of had this like
scandalous love story and I feel like
Taylor's trying to be a little
promiscuous with gorgeous and this and I
mean Elizabeth Taylor she had like eight
marriages Taylor obviously has had a ton
of boyfriends as always in the media so
I loved that line specifically and just
like this whole drinking thing it's an
interesting night no drinking Stowe is
sure slit I'm glad you picked up the
slack on that by the way I thought she
was talking about Tim Burton and I don't
know no reason for it would be totally
different but like you know because it's
kind of like dark and yeah well should
we get into production it's trig into
predictions do it no it's two
predictions I could totally see her
pulling a Beyonce and dropping this
album with every single track having a
visual and for me I think Taylor's music
really comes to life when she shows us
the music videos for example like shake
it off from 1989
hmm liked the song totally catchy but
when I saw the video I was like loving
it this is dope
good for you teh love the creativity for
me the reason why I like Swift is
because of how creative she is I don't
think it's that creative I I'm I'm a
shaken contrarian I'm the only person in
the world who doesn't like shake it off
everyone Taylor Swift Ainur yeah bad
blood is like the greatest pop song well
one of the greatest pop songs in the
21st century but I agree with you the
visuals are interesting
behind us is miked Halloween costume
look at this this is awesome you know
she wears this in the you belong with me
vid is so way back in the day this is
old old Tay and a lot of fans are also
asking if she's going to drop a new
single before the album comes out I
could maybe see that happening at the
time we were filming this the ready for
it video didn't come out yet but we know
that's coming we saw a clip of that
basically she's kind of it looks like
she's naked almost she's like a robot
there's some like et vibes in there it's
like naked Tron or what's that it's like
ex machina yes I don't know I think
Taylor's doing a little much with her
videos these days I think bad blood was
a perfect video yeah she stands on a
horse no animals were harmed in the
making of that video but um but uh I
don't know on to prediction number two
will she poke more fun at herself and
make digs at frenemies I'm gonna go
ahead and say yes to this we heard the
three songs she obviously did it with
look what you made me do
I don't think she's done doing it I want
to say she'll probably be maybe a little
less straightforward than she was on
some of the other tracks but yeah I'm
pretty straightforward yeah like if the
first three songs if the the trilogy of
new Taylor mm-hmm
is any indication she's pretty blunt and
and also I don't think you can even say
frenemies anymore I think she just she
just doesn't like these people yeah I
mean I inland look what you made me do
last summer
[Laughter]
and look what she made me do she says I
don't like you mm-hmm I mean straight to
the point it's really cute it's kind of
like yeah but if she could do something
crazy and maybe like have Kanye come on
the album who knows I would I would
literally die me too Abbi awesome I
don't think it's gonna happen yeah but
you never know you never know Kris
Jenner get on it yes so on to number
three three what will the other songs be
called so we had a lot of fun with this
one we don't actually know what any of
these are going to be we're just
guessing we pulled some of our staff we
asked some people on Twitter and we kind
of pulled some of our favorites yeah
which we have right here so let's just
like run down the list okay you want to
kick it off I want you to kick it off
because I like the second one better
than the first one all right first one
savage which is obviously a reference to
her feud with Kim Kardashian yes okay
Savage that's good it's in the news kids
are saying Savage these guys second one
my boyfriend just got carded go all win
he's young he's young in case you didn't
know he can't be on his parent's
insurance anymore he's 26 he's 26 years
yes
yeah he's 26 he's got to get that nutter
so crazy so young the next one famous on
my own how that makes that's yes like
the song famous yeah obviously to Kanye
West that famous line I made famous
don't at me which I love I think don't
at me is is the best one on here because
like look what she made me do mm-hmm
ready for it gorgeous kind of goes away
from it but it's like passive-aggressive
right just statements so yeah this is me
don't at me is kind of aggressive but I
like it oh it's awesome
it'll be great if she doesn't whatever
okay next one you this is your favorite
I think I have a boyfriend and I'm happy
baby spit like a big dream walking with
his head down monies back into and then
the last one is live free which actually
takes us on to our next prediction
number four will there be any
collaborations so I bring this up
because a lot of fans have been saying
that they think Kesha is gonna be a part
of this album
the reason being a long time ago Kesha
posted this picture on Instagram she's
wearing these headphones and if you look
very very very closely it looks like
they're actually Taylor's headset yeah
interesting then she took it one step
further in the caption and she basically
wrote like oh I am recording with this
casual grammy-winning person and then
she put 13 emojis which is obviously
taste favorite lucky number and then she
also got tattoos on her knuckles that
they live free in the font of what looks
like reputation has sure got real
tattoos yeah I mean we don't know if
that's what feature you never know
that's just a theory out there we don't
know if this is true whatever you say
each I'm guessing she has a bad track
record with friends no I could you see
catch it on the elbow okay I think she
if there is gonna be a feature I think
it definitely will be heard what Halen
doesn't do a lot of features right we
got Kendrick Lamar mm-hmm on one did I
point at it or did I not point at it he
pointed out I think I think Amaro was
one Jack Antonoff was kind of yeah he's
like his voice like that yeah
I don't know if she has a feature I
think would be him yeah and then on to
number five how will this album rank
compared to the others do you think her
fans are ready for this side of her know
why cuz I like it so much I feel like
everyone's gonna hate it I want to I
want to take it back to the greatest
living artist Kanye West so alex is a
big big Kanye West fan I feel like
you're gonna be talking about him a lot
on the show which I'm okay with he's
gonna get a mention every episode
probably most likely so Kanye I was in
high school when graduation came out
right and that was like his like at the
time peak like it had a stronger
[Music]
that was a great whole bunch of jams
it's great at karaoke by the way but he
followed it up obviously like his mom
died you know and then he got out of a
relationship of like six years yeah and
he releases 808s which is like this like
sad electro album mostly made on like an
808 drum machine and I wonder is this
gonna be heard that like is this her
like least commercially successful album
because it's like the most honest I
don't know I don't know I could see that
I do think that fans are ready for it
well the Swifties are ready yeah they
are they're yeah and the thing is like
her fans are so loyal that you know the
diehards are obviously no matter what
she puts out they're gonna love it but
for the people that you know sometimes
like Swift maybe not so much other times
I think that's gonna be interesting
she's yeah it's not just about the
diehards but yeah cuz she's too big to
fail she is the banks like she is Bernie
Sanders hates heart you know what I mean
like I'm sorry
but like that's the thing is like
everyone even if you don't like her you
can't I guess what can escape her music
I can't escape shake it off yeah which
you know not my favorite Taylor Swift
song but but is is widely regarded it's
like yeah but bad blood well Bob Lowe
was great but I wanted to mention blank
space yeah swing space is great um
interesting to to know I think is that
when she released 1989 before that the
only song she gave us was shake it off
and she's given us three with us why do
you think she did that that's a good
question and the fact that ready for it
was so rushed I do wonder if it was kind
of a like a in response to look what you
made me do getting kind of mixed that's
what I was thinking we use getting made
fun of even though I thought it was
great it's just it just didn't have a
hook in Taylor Swift has hooks like
that's her thing you know so uh I guess
we're gonna have to wait and on that
note we're gonna wrap up the show but we
want to of course know what you guys
think are you excited about the album do
you think our predictions are accurate
or you horley off yeah or do you miss
the old Taylor just let us know this has
been new Jam's I'm Alex
you can find me on Twitter at Alex
Dunkelman and I'm Desiree Murphy at
Desiree Murphy underscore on all social
media if you liked our show go ahead and
give us a like and of course hit that
subscribe button and if you want more
info and anything we discussed today
check out the description area below
Chihuahua is old enough to rent a car
you